[Music]
all right so when you first got here
uh there were ants everywhere there was
office
and you sprayed raid everywhere was
outside i had no breakfast
yeah no breakfast because it was pretty
crazy we're the most
down-to-earth office you've ever stepped
into and there was one point i was like
this
and i was just mushing up until they
attacked my breakfast she was typing
like my dad on a keyboard
[Laughter]
where is that damn that's how my dad
types
to this day and you asked uh what are
the purpose of ants
i did i said why do we have ants
i know why we have bees we need bees for
agriculture they pollinate
those things because we are running out
of bees and then honey
honey and i said before any genocide
people always ask this question
yes why do we need why do we need ants
because i needed to know
what their purpose actually is
i thought ants were for the they're like
the garbage pickers of the
nature like they pick it up that's what
i thought like larva was
and maggots same wire maybe we need a
whole team of them to do it
true and you just said the bigger
question is why
do we have cockroaches they stink
questions yeah i want to know the why
because they can survive they're
unkillable yeah are we supposed to learn
from are we supposed to learn from them
should we be studying cockroaches closer
have protein
we're supposed to eat them when we run
out of food
maybe nothing means anything and nothing
matters at all oh there we go
for the man in the mouth the good thing
he was muscles
we got candy i loved it i heard 75
percent of it you know what i
love i love the most is that anytime
something is said
all of us can react and i look at it and
i'm like is he smiling
frowning laughing what does he do
can you imagine jk news with all masks
we would sound like the guy from
what is it the crab guy from futurama oh
yeah
there's gonna be people like she's a
[ __ ] it's a patreon stretch goal
all right so the reason why i bring up
cockroaches is because china
china has the world has the biggest
cockroach farm
uh in and where jinan shandong probably
in the world i was about to say the
world but then at the the article
correct
not even within china i was like i was
about to give
credit where credit was not due not in
this province actually
okay cool because clearly there are
other places that have bigger
farms cockroach farms what what is the
purpose of a cockroach farm
i've heard of that is it for uh animal
feed yes that's part of it yeah
i've heard of that beetles are used in
um shellac
nail polish so i know that yeah beetles
are
um juice beetlejuice it's also in
starbucks drinks
wait wait cockroaches are beautiful
beetles like uh the red dye
that's from like a that's like a cheetah
red dye is just wait so when we say
it's like animal free we're like but not
beagles though
oh beetles are in here i think that's
actually it because they fight for
different
like fish and chicken didn't have the
same
because rights as that cute no but
there's like their eyes aren't
expressive why do we have to make the
color red out of very evil things
i know right why can't we just make it
out of like chalk or something that's
how they made it back in the days
needles aren't evil no i'm saying out of
an evil means like killing a beetle and
turning into red that's how we got a lot
of the stuff
back in the day like makeup originated
from uh
burgundy like coal certain things like
eyeliner beetles
flowers a lot of those things that had
bright colors it came from nature so it
wasn't evil back
in the day but now we have evolved like
like oil right oil
like when we burn [ __ ] oil like
candles and [ __ ] like a lot of it came
from whale
the whaling industry was big the good
kind did i'll tell you that yeah we use
[ __ ] animal products for like with
like glue glue is [ __ ]
horse nails or whatever and then when i
find out about jelly like gummy bears
like gummies and that should blew my
that's collagen
collagen yeah so that's why when you
normally see something that's not tested
on animals and the reason why they have
a bunny on it was because they were
testing a lot of products
on bunnies which don't count as animals
which is crazy
you know what and mice so it's crazy
because they've
decided what has feelings and what
doesn't that's why fish have different
rights than other animals well fish look
like they don't deserve as many rice as
them oh my god
fish don't blink though they don't blink
they don't really give you much
expression
and they taste so good and when they're
dead animalist
well when they're dead when they're dead
they look the same as they're alive
fish-ish i mean tell me about it you're
a vicious
fishes vicious fine i'll put it i'll put
it on my [ __ ] twitter you'll put it
on your imbd
i got some crab at the pier and i said i
don't give a [ __ ] if they have feelings
because it tastes so good
did you make it did you grab it okay so
you would be the first one if we're all
on a deserted island you're like you
know what somebody's gonna have to die
i'm eating you first
are you ready or are you gonna go are
you gonna hide and gather first
together to probably get food faster
okay if bart's there i'm just going to
kick it i'm just going to be like oh
we're going to be fine
you do all of our parts no no no no no
no no no no with both bart and joe
i'm like we're going to survive i'll
make them together
yeah but uh wait no okay i might
actually have to get the food
bart could uh teach you guys how to
survive
my little bit of meat you can have it
are you sacrificing yourself for them
i
what are we having for dinner this
evening roast tiff again
oh
all right back to the cockroaches so
apparently i didn't know about this
until i read this
article people actually breed
cockroaches and you'd be like why would
anyone want to breed they stink when you
smash them
cockroaches eat [ __ ] trash they eat
garbage
oh we need it and we have a lot of trash
we do
the landfills is it like how they do
with goats when you have to cultivate
something like that so yeah so there is
a basically an
island this is this warehouse this
hanger like an industrial sized hangar
there's four of them
they're built on in an area where
there's a moat
around the building whoa so it's like
there's a water
around it so if there was ever a
cockroach that wanted to escape
they would be drowned they can't wait
you're kidding
i thought they're unkillable but i feel
like they can't they live in water
they can live in water could they just
swim across this moat
this moat is also infested
by fish that are trained to eat
cockroaches
not piranhas but like imagine like you
know if you're trying to make a run for
it right and that one fish is like
i'm ready for you i'm waiting for
another one to go i like how natural
that is that's cockroach
alcatraz yes and what people are doing
now is sending
trash this island i don't know if it's
an actual island it's just surrounded by
a moat
but they're sending trash there and the
cockroaches are actually just eating
what kind of trash like banana peels
yeah bananas
kind of like bananas okay basically
trash i know we oh so
because we deal with a lot of issues
with diapers
there's a lot of things that are not
decomposing so
can they eat those things right like can
we throw like a
soda can and then they'll eat it can we
train the fish to eat diapers
[Laughter]
right that's why i'm like but are they
actually doing that's why i said
our issues are not with food right
with plastic diapers a lot of those
things that's what doesn't
true yeah don't have enough for that
with this one i assume now they're using
this so that they can
create compost right so maybe they can
sell the compost after the
maybe yeah that's a good point so what
do you do like do you have to get the
cockroach poop yep is that what you're
selling do they not kill these
cockroaches that they're farming
they do so to build a build around the
cockroaches there's actual
land here that is a chicken farm duck
farm pig farm
oh whole bunch of different farmers eat
all the cocktails fish farms yes so they
take these cockroaches who are also just
feeding on garbage uh they they grind
them up
roasted whatever they create like uh
cockroach powder basically
and this is pure protein at this point
and they feed it to the
chickens that's what we're eating dude
the cockroach eats the trash
the chicken eats the cockroach and we
eat the chicken we're eating trash
we're eating trash yes but furthermore
though it's also cheaper to do this than
to
feed corn or grains to chickens and pigs
so therefore it's better therefore it
recycles itself
itself it's more sustainable
self-sustaining that's great on the
label though
it would be like these chickens had a
high protein diet that's right there we
go which is more
gains for us and these high trash diet
and i should say these beetles had a
very sad life
about as sad as you could think of
that's true that's true
would you be down to eat insects instead
of food if food was no longer available
yeah i'm gonna have to adapt i ain't
gonna die we go we're gonna figure it
out but if i have
but if i have the option to not like
you're not gonna catch me on fear factor
for [ __ ] fifty thousand dollars [ __ ]
you i'm not eating no
larva i'm not doing it what's your price
yeah now
yes if we have to adapt i think that
many people have been figuring out
sustainable food options
i don't think that it's too far-fetched
i know that with technology and what we
have now
you wouldn't even be actually feeling
like you're eating a little worm
it's like you could have it in another
form it's not powdered
it's all about it's just we're just way
too advanced so yeah but have you ever
had crickets with lime
and salt wickets taste like shrimp
exactly listen i eat dehydrated shrimp
listen when you are when you grow up and
i'm gonna say when you grow up eating
asian food you eat dehydrated [ __ ]
random [ __ ]
so like the little tiny shrimps or even
like um mexican
you have the little shrimps that you go
the little camera around and they're
they look like
little [ __ ] bugs and you put your
little you guys constantly going to bugs
you can you can live
i'm not even kidding for seven years off
cotton candy did you know that
how is that nutritious where do you get
your protein steve we are getting
protein
he's powered by monster yeah you don't
need you get protein from the sun you
dumb [ __ ]
i feel like steve's staple wait i want
to trust him what sun are you standing
under
what protein you're protein deficient
you get it from moonlight
okay sun gives you vitamin d the moon
gives you the protein
steve staple of 7-eleven oh in hawaii
hey 7-eleven in hawaii what's the
craziest thing you've
ever eaten what's the craziest thing you
put in your mouth yeah like hold on
that's the better
okay
that'll [ __ ] you up that'll [ __ ] you up
dude
hey you know what no culture will claim
it don't tell me
oh it's not that crazy i don't know a
culture that will claim nachos
[Laughter]
[Music]
they got rid of the cool ranch one taco
yeah taco bell's saying goodbye to
everything good
i know they got rid of their throats
they got rid of the [ __ ] mexican
pizza which is a staple from mexico
yeah that was good i think there's only
a couple more weeks left of it i tried
ordering a tostada
two days ago tim was talking about
something like some burrito chick
some chicken burrito something another
mexican staple from mexican culture
gone poof i know my people are suffering
you know
they're like finally now go take your
asses over to the taqueria
go where you're supposed to get these
[Music]
you